It's a truly fascinating algorithm, and if you're interested in it, you should definitely check it out.
It's very closely connected to Euclid's algorithm for
computing GCDs in fact.
But I won't say anything
more about it in this video.
The point of this is that if we have a good
approximation to some fraction for which the numerator and
denominator aren't too big,
the algorithm can recover the fraction, and that's what we're doing here.
And now we're left with exactly
the same question as before, which is how much precision do we need?
And it turns out that
exactly the same bound that we had before works in this case.
And so choosing M in exactly
the same way as before works here as well.
Now this isn't necessarily
going to tell us R.
What we'll learn if we use
enough precision, is J over R, but that will be a
fraction in lowest terms.
So we could get unlucky in the sense that this random choice of J could have common factors with R,
and they'll be hidden from us. In the worst case for instance, we could get J equals zero and we will learn absolutely nothing.
But that is literally the only
case where we learn nothing.
In general, we'll at least
get a non-trivial factor of R, and if we're able to draw random samples
and get psi J for different choices of J, we can in fact recover
R with high probability by computing the least common multiple
of all of the denominators
that we observe. And this actually doesn't
require very many samples at all.
The bottom line is that some choices of J will hide factors of R, but random choices of J
won't be able to hide the
factors of R for long.
So that is the idea. It remains to consider the implementation and in particular to figure
out how much it costs.
The essence of the idea, to compute the order of a
given element A and ZN star is to apply the phase estimation procedure
to the operation MA.
Let's figure out what
the cost of doing this is as a function of the length of capital N, which I'll denote by little n.
Here's a circuit for phase estimation. We're going to need little n qubits on the bottom part of the circuit
to encode elements of ZN in binary. So we have N control qubits on top and little n qubits on the bottom,
which is nice because that matches with the names that we
used earlier in the lesson.
In order to count the
number of gates that we need for the entire circuit, let's focus first on the cost of the controlled unitary operations.
If we use the techniques
from the previous lesson, lesson six, we can implement MA using big O of little n squared gates
using efficient classical algorithms for arithmetic modular N.
I'll skip the details in this video, but like several other
things I've talked about, you can read more about it in the written material for the lesson.
It's not enough though
to implement just MA.
We also need to implement MA squared, MA to the fourth power, to
the eighth power, and so on
all the way up to MA to a power that's exponential in M.
And we know we're going to need to take M to be linear in little n
to get enough precision.
This is a big concern,
and I raised it earlier.
If we were to implement powers
of MA by simply iterating MA, we'd be in trouble because all these iterations of MA
would incur exponential cost.
Fortunately, we can play a trick to avoid this blow up in cost.
What we can do is as follows, for each power K that we need.
First, we compute A to
the power K, modular N.
This is the modular exponentiation problem that I mentioned in lesson six.
And it can be solved efficiently. And this is something that we can do with a classical computer.
This computation doesn't
need to be performed by a quantum circuit at all.
So let's let B be the result.
So B is an element of ZN star.
And second, in place of MA to the power K, we just use a circuit for MB.
And that's it. B is just some element of ZN star, So the cost to implement MB
is big O of little n squared.
In a nutshell, what we're doing is exponentating in ZN rather than exponentating
a quantum circuit.
But the actual operation we
get is the same either way. It's just multiplication by A, K times.
This is kind of a miracle in fact. And we wouldn't be able to
solve the order finding problem or effect integers efficiently
with a quantum computer
if it wasn't for this.
And now that we know that each of the controlled
unitary operations, including the powers, can be implemented
at cost big O events squared, we can count the total
number of gates we need.
We have N Hadamard gates, and because M is equal
to big O of little n, the cost is big O of little n.